عمرو دياب ببيروت في حفله قبلت بالحفاوه
والجدل تفاعل واسع مع حفل كاسيت 90 في جده
ومحمد الحلو في مرمى الانتقادات واول
تعليق من بريتني سبيرز بعد انفصالها عن
سام اصغري اليكم الابرز في اسبوع
[موسيقى]
كان مساء السبت 19 اغسطس موعدا طال
انتظاره ل 12 عاما للقاء عشاق الفنان
المصري عمرو دياب في لبنان وقدر عدد حضور
الحفل في بيروت ب 18
وسط اجراءات امنيه خاصه وحظي الحفل بتفاعل
كبير على منصات التواصل في لبنان احتفاء
بليله المنتظره للهضبه وانتقادا لصيغه
التعهد التي طلب من الصحفيين الحاضرين
للحفل ان يوقعوا عليها وتضمنت بنودا
استنكرها صحفي لبنانيون ومما جاء فيها
التعهد بنقل وقائع الحفل بشكل ايجابي
والالتزام بعدم التصريح او كتابه اي مقال
او منشور من شانه الاساءه لقيمه الحفل او
لعمرو دياب او الشركه المنظمه وعبر وزير
الاعلام اللبناني زياد مكاري في منشور له
على منصه اكس تويتر سابقا عن اسفه للجدل
الحاصل المتعلق بحفل عمرو دياب في بيروت
واوضح انه بعد التواصل مع الجهه المنظمه
تبين بان التعهد المذكور كان موجها الى
الصحفيين الراغبين بالضغطيه في كواليس
المسرح فقط وتوجه وزير الاعلام اللبناني
بالشكر لعمرو دياب وختم منشوره قائلا نؤكد
بان بيروت نسمه تنعش الفن العربي وصحافتها
حره لا توضع عليها قيود الا التي تفرضها
اخلاقيات المهنه
ومن ليله عمرو دياب في بيروت الى ليله
كاسيت 90 التي جمعت نخبه من ابرز نجوم
غناء مصر التسعينيات في جده
[موسيقى]
وحظيت بتفاعل كبير على منصات التواصل
ليله انعش الذكريات جيلان باكمله باجمل
اغاني تلك الحقبه التي لا تزال في البال
وكان مفاجاتها الفنان المصري محمد الحلو
الذي ادى اغنيه تتر المسلسل الايقوني
ليالي الحلميه
[موسيقى]
لكن استبدال الحلو عباره عمار يا سعوديه
بعمارس اسكندريه خلال ادائه لتتر مسلسل
زيزينيا اغضب مصريين على منصات التواصل
بينما وجد اخرون في ذلك مجامله يمكن
تبريرها للفنان المصري الذي قوبل مع
زملائه بحفاوه كبيره في المملكه ودعوا الى
عدم المغالاه في انتقاده
[موسيقى]
انا مره واحده كده رحت قايل وعمار يا
سعوديه فانا حبيت يعني اعمل لهم كده واشعل
الفنان المصري محمد رمضان حماسه الجمهور
في حفل احياء وايضا ضمن فعاليات تقويم جده
الاسبوع الماضي
[موسيقى]
واخيرا علقت نجمه البوب الامريكيه على
اتصالها عن سام اصغري في مشهورين عبر
حسابها الرسمي على انستجرام قالت فيه ست
سنوات هي فتره طويله لتكون مع شخص ما لذلك
انا مصدومه قليلا لست هنا لاشرح السبب
لانه بصراحه لا احد يهمني لكني لم استطع
تحمل الالم بعد الان
واضافت من المفترض ان تكون محبوبا بدون
قيد او شرب ليس بشروط لذلك ساكون قويه قدر
الامكان وسابذل خساره جهدي وظهرت بريتني
في مقطع فيديو نشرته لاحقا وهي تحاول
الاستمتاع مع اصدقائها وكانت ثنائي قد
تزوج رسميا حزيران 2022 واخر صوره نشرها
اصغر عبر حسابه الرسميه على انستجرام
جماعتهما معا كانت في عيد الميلاد الماضي